[Musique]
elle est arrivée toute fraîche toute
belle toute neuve dans son écrin de
lumière c'est la paloise série 7 alors
allez paris des seuls l arrivée avec un
bracelet on va donc aujourd'hui regardez
ce à quoi ressemble la perla world
series 7 je sais pas si vous avez
regardé la conférence d'apple là qui
note la grande qui note du mois de
septembre où apple présente toutes les
nouveautés sont présentes et bien
évidemment les iphone les compagnies
bref mais l'apple walsh et reset alors
je vous le dis je reste un peu sur ma
faim parce que j'attendais des nouveaux
capteurs dans cette apple welsh série 7
est ce que tous les problèmes que
connaissent aujourd'hui un peu la tech
avec nombre de matières premières avec
des problèmes d'acheminement ont fait
qu'on n'a pas vu arriver ces capteurs
allez savoir peut-être sur une apple
watch series 8 qui arrivera normalement
l'année prochaine pour l'instant ici on
va prendre du plaisir oui parce que
c'est le quart à découvrir cet appel au
roi le cheikh issa est parce que
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait cet aveu richard
il est regardé j'ai voulu montrer on va
se couvrir directement elle monte de
joux les choses et surtout au niveau de
l'écran et au niveau de la charge ce qui
est le point principal convenir tenir
ici hop
regardez ces jolis ils font toujours des
super beau packaging une belle
expérience au niveau de l'oeil boxing
ici sur ses montres alors là je vous ai
dit la série si ce qu'on va regarder
pour comparer parce qu'il ya une vraie
différence au niveau de l'écran et c'est
ce qu'on va venir chercher ensemble gelé
avec un petit bracelet qui est sympa sur
le dessous avec une autre alternative en
bracelet on va se regarder dans quelques
instants ensuite ça s'ouvre juste ici on
prend on tire je tire fort comme si
j'étais en train d'arracher une bande de
cire voyez en mode épilation va pas
perdre de temps avec ça qu'on laisse
coup un peu comme un cocotier et
normalement on devrait voir arriver la
montre qui ne saurait tarder voilà ici
elle est présentée en modèle vert donc
on va la voir en verte ça s'ouvre ça
s'ouvre à sa souvient sûr que ça s'ouvre
ça se glisse ça se pousse voilà ça c'est
la paloise série 7 il ya du 41e du 45 mm
qui existent alors qu'avant l'été sur du
cac 40 et du 44 mm donc ça c'est
intéressant et vous allez voir que le
nouvel écran n'y est pas pour rien
ensuite à l'intérieur on va mieux
retrouver sa recharge alors la recharge
elle est super intéressante et c'est un
des gros points forts qu apple nous a
senti cette année pourquoi il demandé et
bien parce qu'en fait on a un chargeur
qui sera plus rapide ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle parce que avec ses montres et
cette fois ci si non plus ne déroge pas
là et vous devez la recharger tous les
jours vous avez une autonomie d'un jour
max je vous passe il ya les docks si à
l'intérieur on connaît la reine bien
nouveau sous le soleil donc la charge
c'est une des grosses nouveautés on va
se regarder ça aussi dans quelques
instants mais avant toute chose on voit
cela configurer avant de la configurer
on va regarder ce qu'on a aussi en
termes de bracelets je pense que marié a
souhaité qu'un petit peu sympa hop là on
prend condé zip on ouvre au très joli
j'adore ce petit verre n'a montré dans
une espèce de verre un peu canard vous
êtes d'accord sur le vert un peu canard
c'est un vert un peu foncé en fait donc
avec un bracelet vert ça va être hyper
hyper hyper jolie elle s'allume
directement et ce qui va être
intéressant c'est de voir parce qu'en
fait c'est la première fois qu'apple
nous fait un petit écran incurvé et
c'est intéressant pourquoi parce que une
montre à la différence de smartphones
convient tout en m face à soi une montre
on peut la voir un petit peu sur le côté
alors on va pas la regarder sur le côté
pour autant néanmoins ça va être
intéressant alors pour venir faire ça
qu'est ce qu'on fait on prend son iphone
qu'on ouvre comme ça qu'est ce qui se
passe il me regarda il ya une apple ou
âge ça vous intéresse de configurer gill
a bien évidemment on va la configurer
mon lapin on y va donc la configurer
pour moi même je place hop là le cadran
comme ça attendez se veulent mais ça va
voilà il l'a reconnu et maintenant on va
restaurer une sauvegarde laissez nous un
peu de temps je vais la restaurer en
même temps on va venir mettre à jour
pour arriver sur dernière version de 2
watts chômage bien évidemment donc on va
la laisser un petit peu pédales et on se
la met de côté on va regarder ce dernier
bracelet et on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour voir ce que nous propose
cette nouvelle apple watch regardez
également ce qu'il en est savoir quel
apple watch acheter parce que
aujourd'hui on n'a pas que cet apple
watch série 7 il ya la série 6 qui n'est
plus sur le marché qu'apple ne
commercialise plus aimé qu'on peut
trouver je pense l'occasion d'en réduire
conditionné ça peut paraître un petit
peu logique puis il ya la paloise series
3 qui est toujours commercialisé par
apple on a à la pelle watch et ce qui
est aussi extrêmement intéressantes dont
je vous ai déjà parlé l'année dernière
regardez ce petit bracelet la hausse est
mignon watch nike alors comme disent les
américains c'est pas nike c'est mike et
donc ça c'est le bracelet qui est fait
avec nike alors je sais pas si ce petit
quai kivalliq mauvais rosso va le faire
c'est parce que vous pourrez faire des
redites le mans commentaire est ce que
vous préférez ce petit verre là un peu
forestier printanier où est ce que vous
préférez ce petit ce petit marronner
très sympathique au très automnale moi
évidemment bas en commentaire à lens une
petite pause on se retrouve tout de
suite
après l'ouest mise à jour avec le
dernier os donc là ça fonctionne
regardèrent ce qui est intéressant ce
qu'il faut venir regarder on garde le
même châssis mais l'écran est plus grand
je vous mets le même cadre en accéléré
et vous le voyez ici on a plus de bord
noir sur la watch séries6 que sur la web
série 7 est l'intérêt de la wachkyrie 7
c'est qu'on a un écran qui est aussi
légèrement incurvé et c'est la première
fois qu'on a ça chez apple et c'est
plutôt pas mal or les nouveaux cadrans
vous avez le cadran contours que je vous
ai montré tout à l'heure qui est ici
alors le cadran contours il est
intéressant on pourrait bien changer
soit style arrondi soit style standard
mettre une couleur au fond changer la
couleur on peut vraiment venir
personnalisé ça qui est très très sympa
avec ce cadran donc là si vous regardez
regardez sur le côté on voit un petit
peu les chiffres sur le bas et la
regarder sur le bas on le voit là
vraiment cet écran qui est incurvé alors
c'est assez sympa ça apportera plus de
profondeur sera plus agréable lorsque
vous allez venir effectivement regarder
votre monde ont cassé le tout premier
cadran et qui est vraiment intéressant
vous avez d'autres cadres en l'horloge
mondiale qui vous permet d'avoir soit de
l'analogique soit du numérique comme on
le souhaite pour échanger aussi la
couleur on vient vraiment personnalisé
ça c'est vachement bien et après vous dé
racheter ce qu'on appelle des
complications qui permettront de
personnaliser en ajoutant des petits
modules tient un petit module météo ici
le petit module uv qui me va bien vous
avez également le modulaire duo alors le
modulaire du haut on peut changer
effectivement aussi la couleur les
complications uv ici on peut mettre la
lune ici on peut venir ajouter autre
chose astronomie la bourse bref les
décibels il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de possibilités donc à vous de
voir comment voulez venir le
personnaliser mais pouvait faire un peu
ce que vous voulez et puis ensuite si
vous le souhaitez vous pouvez venir
ajouter dans les nouveaux cadrans et
bien le portrait vous venez zoomer
dézoomer bon il ya un côté un peu rigolo
avec ses cadrans on peut faire vivre ces
photos donc ça c'est pareil c'est assez
marrant le niveau de personnalisation va
assez loin et ça c'est très très sympa
et surtout ce qui intéresse vraiment
c'est un nouvel écran avec ses bords
plus fin vous aurez donc plus de contenu
qui va venir être affichées directement
ici se rappelle au walsh et reset donc
ça c'est vraiment très très très
agréable elle est donc plus confortable
à venir utiliser mais il ya notre
bénéfice qui arrivent et qui s'appelle
aussi à l'esat et je voulais montrer
tout à l'heure et bien c'est ça l'année
dernière on avait ça et c'est vrai que
globalement on peut venir utiliser celui
de l'année dernière avec l'appel aux
aciéries 7 sauf que le nouveau qu'on va
retrouver ici sur la série 7 ira plus
vite plus vite donc là c'est beaucoup
mieux une autre différence que vous
retrouvez ici c'est qu'avant vous aviez
de l'usb a maintenant vous avez lu sbc
alors forcément pas venir utiliser les
mêmes blocs de charbon avec un usb à et
bien j'utilisais mon bloc de charge 5
watts quant aux clasicos d'apple tandis
que avec de nouveau bien là et bien je
vais utiliser celui là en usb c'est ça
me permet ici d'avoir une charge qui va
être plus rapide 33 % plus rapide par
rapport à ce qu'on avait avant longtemps
vous dire que ça va aller beaucoup plus
loin et ça c'est vachement sympa donc
vous allez passer moins pas en venir
recharger votre montre ça vous évitera
de venir la charge et toute la nuit
parce que c'est pas forcément la bonne
idée vouloir charger le matin lorsque
vous vous préparez ou alors le soir
vouloir charger vous la débrancher pour
que puisse être tranquille toute la nuit
ce qui vous permet en gros en huit
minutes de charge d'être parti pour huit
heures alors la durée de la batterie de
la plage on reste toujours sur une
journée mais bien que le changement
principal c'est la contrainte du temps
de chargement ça va plus vite c'est pas
dans le sens de l'histoire il y aussi
une nouveauté ici cet apple watch elles
et ip 6 x alors ip66 ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'elle est résistant à la
poussière avant que déjà résistantes à
l'eau donc on peut aller se baigner avec
on peut aller nager avec on peut aller
faire du sport aller à la piscine
transpire sans aucun problème mais
maintenant tout ce qui va être poussière
et bien on craindre à moi on a également
vers qui va être plus solide alors
l'idée ce n'est pas de venir taper
dessus mais si vous venez taper dessus
il ya des chocs et bien elle est
protégée et à ce sujet c'est intéressant
ça peut le match venait là protégé grâce
au code de protection de mon partenaire
rhinochill parce que oui même une apple
watch peut être protégé on a un verre
plus résistants elle est résistante à la
poussière mais des fois vaut mieux pas
chercher un peu l'histoire donc vous
mettez une protection de rideau chine il
en existe de toutes les couleurs on peut
venir les customiser les personnalisées
directement sur le site de rhinau chine
je vous aime il ya la description aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil et en plus de
ça vous avez 5 % de réduction avec le
code greu 21 tout est en bas dans la
description profitez-en parce que avoir
de jolimont c'est bien la protéger ça
peut être intéressant alors la regarde
et il a joué dans cette jolie couleur
vert meilleur plein de nouvelles
couleurs de l'est pourra retrouver
directement sur le site d'apple donc
quelles que soient vos goûts vos envies
et bien votre votre bonheur et autres
trucs qui est intéressant c'est que les
bracelets sont toujours les mêmes
identique donc si vous avez une grande
collection bracelet et bien vous allez
pouvoir venir les appliquer ici
directement sur votre apple welsh série
7 il ya eu également des nouveautés au
niveau de oued choisissez watchou s8
elles ont été présentées lors de la
table ronde à bellou d'ici au mois de
juin niveau performances et la même
chose on a le même processeur qu'on a vu
sur l'apple oil series 6 vous avez
toujours les mêmes capteurs cas plus de
votre taux d'oxygène dans le sang
toujours faire un ecg bref tout ce que
vous aviez embarqué dans votre appel aux
world series 6 vous l'avez ici dans
votre appel au hc reset donc les grosses
nouveautés et les grands bénéfices ça va
être cet écran qui va être plus grand et
incurvé avec des bords plus fin ce avec
le fait qu elle est résistante à la
poussière avec le fait qu'elle se
recharge plus vite avec une connectique
en usb c'est un écran plus lumineux plus
confortable à venir utiliser mais dans
les faits sinon il n'y a pas grande
différence donc si vous aviez déjà une
api web série 6 gardez là très
clairement garder là il n'y a pas
d'intérêt à venir la changer si par
contre vous avez un peu l'oreille series
3 on peut encore acheter aujourd'hui eh
bien ça peut prendre un coup de switcher
sur votre apple ouest salle et 7 parce
que vous avez pas mal de nouveaux
capteurs par rapport à la 3 et le design
a quand même vraiment changé les bords
sont plus fins et l'écran est plus grand
par rapport à la 3 si vous avez une s e
conserver également votre foyer soleil a
pas vraiment france à venir changer
parce que aujourd'hui il voulait doter
ici sur mon petit patrick pourquoi venir
acheter la pelloche série 7 déjà parce
que vous n'avez pas d'apple watch et
vous vous dites bien que ça pourrait
être sympa d'avoir une apple watch et
que cette dernière apple watch elle me
fait de l'oeil donc là très clairement
on peut y aller on est chez apple on
veut une apple watts vous pouvez y aller
sans aucun problème il faut quand même
avoir les 429 euros c'est le tarif
d'entrée pour venir acheter cette mon
club mais ça c'est déjà un vrai gros
prérequis ensuite vous vous dites ah ah
mince j'ai pas 429 euros j'ai un peu
moins de 300 euros eh bien j'ai à 299
euros j'ai la paloise est ce qui est
parfaite qui a plein de capteurs pour le
sport qui est très bien bref c'est un
excellent modèle je vous ai déjà
présenté l'année dernière en vidéo vous
pouvez toujours aller la voir et c'est
une montre qui reste complètement
actuelle qui est très bien vous pouvez
également acheter la paix au vestiaire
et 3 219 euros clairement essayer de
rajouter un petit peu plus d'aller sur
la est ce parce que la série 3 la came
pris un petit coup de vieux même si
apple la propose encore son site est
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant qu'apple ne
propose plus du tout la perla world
series 6 propose que l'apple wash series
7 aujourd'hui qui vient vraiment la
remplacer mais pour autant si vous
croisez une série 6 moins cher vous
pouvez y aller parce que c'est vraiment
une superbe montre va tout ce que
j'avais à vous dire aujourd'hui sur
cette montre je ne vais pas aller
forcément aller plus loin dans le test
parce qu'on reste sur la même montre par
rapport à ce qu'on avait avant
l'autonomie va être sensiblement la même
l'écran est un peu plus grand mais
au-delà de ce côté écran plus grand au
delà de la résistance à la poussière au
delà des nouveaux whiteface que vous
avez il n'y a pas grande grande
nouveauté et je parle et vous tester un
nouveau capteur qu'il n'ya pas ici on
attendra de voir ce qui se passera
l'année prochaine avec cet appel ou h
series 8 devrait arriver en 2022 en tout
cas on va surveiller ça c'est
intéressant et on se retrouve très très
très rapidement parce qu'apple est
encore plein de nouveautés plein
d'annoncés on en reparle bientôt donc je
vous invite à venir vous abonner à
actionner la cloche si ce n'est pas déjà
fait sur ses jambes rast des bisous et
premiers soins ciao
[Musique]